obviously a different kind of game there
from the start just the initial sequence
did you see it uh and what did you think
of the whole res resolution of it um
there's no way Klay Thompson should have
been thrown out of the game I mean he's
running up the floor and he the guy
grabs his jersey and he's pulling on him
and so clay pulls back and uh no way
clay should have been ejected that was
ridiculous um so I was upset about that
and then uh the Draymond piece of it um
if you watch the replay Rudy had his
hands on Clay's neck and that's why
Draymond went after Rudy and that's I
saw one replay um right after it
happened um guys on the back of the
bench were telling us uh that Rudy had
Draymond or had clay and that's why
Draymond went went at Rudy so that's all
I all I know um but it was yeah bizar
way to start the game a minute and a
half
in